[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der tag sei in der hall of freedom
als basis das unentschuldbare noch nicht
festgestellt und doch eine regel die
erfindung einer regel als ereignis im
herzen der regel anwendung gespenster
des nichts im lichte höchster freiheit
gibt es gründe verursachung von freiheit
als deren tod anti freiheit
ursachenforschung holzwege begründung
probleme was können wir sollen was
sollen wir wollen was kann ich wollen
[Musik]
die
darf ich sie gerade nicht nur
[Musik]
was sie sehen ist nichts weiter
ein einfacher mensch wenn sie mich sehen
ins land
[Musik]
[Applaus]
o
[Musik]
momentan wartet
[Applaus]
euro
[Musik]
nein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich wollte gesehen gehört in hallstatt
gefühl wahrgenommen wie ein feuerwehr
die das ich mich gerne öffnet und
leuchtet der körper ist ein stand auf
dem politischen sozialen fragen
aufeinanderprallen die wohl dann den
herzschlag im bauchnabel hat das gebiet
jeder ist für sich selbst verantwortlich
aber auch bis in den hafen ihn in seiner
form und kenntlich werden lassen
wie ist der körper an sich eigentlich
auch ganz logisch also dass wir
vielleicht anders gesetzt meine ganze
ohne es zu bemerken was beim aufstehen
hatte ich schon das gibt natürlich auf
die anderen verlassen zu können
ingo verortet man sich in der die
raketen seien um die eigene angst
dorthin gehören wohl sein
wenn seine meinung und seine bösen bei
uns erhalten ist eine ziemlich starke
demokratie ist für mich vor allem
anderen erleben ich kann das alles beim
alten zu schaffen
orientieren müssen aber ein dass man
andere menschen die nach deren immerhin
äußeren einflüssen beantwortet sondern
nicht immer alles kommen nach anderen
richtungen gesperrt oder sie ist nicht
möglich und zwar in ihrer möglichkeit im
alltag ihrer unfassliche widersprüche
zeigen und sie erst noch 1 7 aus heißt
zwar gehe der krise des kapitalismus
weiß so lancierungen mit den
gesellschaften also blog eingehen dessen
friends in seinem sohn bestimmt kann es
eine kunst die man sie mal wieder rum
sondern ist selbst auferlegt
[Musik]
der andere
in der 83
[Musik]
nicht nur chef
ein
[Musik]
ok
über schnee
[Musik]
nein
hier ist die frage nicht
man soll entstehen und kandidiert
[Musik]
nicht
bei
[Musik]
denn
wir sind was machen wir
[Musik]
da das fleisch von daher werden wir
reden aneinander vorbei
vorsicht
tatsächlich seien hier in die andere
dabei entsteht kein austausch der
äußerung wer irgendeinen geschlossen
die alle davon
[Musik]
sie hat viele feinde
doch fragen wofür eigentlich
[Musik]
wenn sie ausbrechen
laut dem kleinsten 10 und die sonst zu
sehen den anschein als reines nach sich
wenn es uns allerdings die partie
einsetzen
oder dass wie auch schon
den augen
nicht vom echten
ebenfalls lieber in berlin
auf zuspiel ungerechtigkeiten
aufzuschlagen
nebenan einfach
vielleicht
[Musik]
nach
hinter
[Musik]